right now the first day of the 2021
session of the nevada legislature in
carson city
is done the budget education and of
course fixing unemployment is going to
be the big issues they're going to try
to tackle
eight news now is the only local station
on the ground at the state capitol and
the i-team david charns is also in
carson city tonight for us david
good evening there denise well the
session kicking off with all the
traditional pomp and circumstance
but with masks and covid tests all
lawmakers their staff
us as well having to get tested before
we entered the building
then it was sort of business as usual
though sort of social distance
throughout the building you could say
new lawmakers sworn in
leadership named the big topics this
year
how to pay for state services with money
we don't have because of loss of revenue
during the pandemic
and some republicans want to look at the
governor's executive power
specifically when it comes to the
shutdown we saw last year and now the
restrictions were currently in
right now next you'll hear from
democratic leadership and then from
republicans as they respond take a
listen and i think the tough part
frankly
is that the legislature is only here 120
days every other year
and so of course we work with the
governor of course we're making sure
that we're part of those conversations
and i commend him for really being in a
very impossible situation
it is an awful lot of power in one
branch of government
and there needs to be some kind of
checks and balances and
not a dig on this governor any any other
it could be another party that could be
in the governor's mansion but i believe
it involves
all branches of our government to be
involved
well the word of the day is certainly
compromise at least for today
and that's something echoed by newly
elected assemblywoman annie black now
you may remember that name
she is the clark county republican who
attended president trump's stop the
steel rally taking these photos and
videos
she was at the protest outside the
capitol but she did not go inside and
did not have anything to do with the mob
now some democrats had called for her to
resign her seat
even before she was sworn in today but
she told me today she's being welcomed
here with open arms
they respect my first amendment rights
free speech and
i didn't break any laws so that's what
they're telling me that's
so that's all i know
now the legislature kicked off today
with two vacant seats one in the
assembly
and one in the senate the clark county
commission will fill
those vacancies tomorrow we're live in
carson city tonight i'm david charns 8
news now